can you make my hair look like his I
won't heard a lot of years no I want my
hair to look like yours you want a sandy
I want the pack here Nick
hi I'm gqueues Marc Anthony green by day
I'm a writer for the magazine and by
night but I'm not searching for exotic
hand lotions and leather pants I'm
hanging out at our barber shop at
Barclays Center getting haircuts and
talking with interesting people
hopefully they don't got my hair too bad
are there any news people anchors in
your family no I just think what made
you want to do it I was interested in it
from like six years old I had a I loved
veneers and VI L was always interested
in broadcasting you had to be a really
cool kid loving the news at 6:00
you know hey you're messing with me yeah
has there ever been a news story that
was like your most difficult well I mean
the two most difficult would be
September 11th and hurricane sandy tens
of thousands of people out of their
houses entire neighborhood burning down
crane dangling above 57th Street half of
Manhattan without power I mean any one
of those things is a big straight ahead
of all at the same time a few of the
editors and I that lived in Brooklyn we
had to walk to our office in Times
Square I didn't walk home one so
actually I've walked most of the way
home and literally at the Williamsburg
Bridge some guys saw that I was trying
to hail a cab to get over the bridge and
he's okay we're going either side jump
in I always like to hear about New
Yorkers being decent you know like
that's good a lot of that happens in New
York you get a bad rap New Yorkers are
infamously tough on their sports teams
yeah are they just as tough on their
anchors so people are very nice like
like 99 of the 100 interactions with
people it's I ride the subway home every
day I'm more often than not going to
having a conversation with them for five
minutes
always very favorable tell us about when
you wake up and what time you have to be
at work if we work it for let me speak
on behalf of all GQ editors if we had a
307 wake-up time you guys would get one
magazine a year it would be gentleman's
yearly you know one of these guys it's
on the subway at 9:00
I'm one of those guys I feel good about
being on the subway and I feel
accomplished can I just say though I'd
rather be wedged between two obese New
Yorkers then have to get up at 3:30
everything all right well we all pick
our path that's the beautiful thing
about America you know what's the
biggest difference between Canadians and
Americans I think it's true that
Canadians are exceedingly polite yeah
Americans are more opinionated so you're
really big on social media the kids
would say your Twitter game is dope oh
that's good twitter is fantastic both
for dissemination of news and for news
gathering Twitter's a big part of the
way that news gets whatever so you hear
that American people it's not just all
selfies and games and hashtags great
segue to my next question okay Justin
Bieber I apologize on behalf of Canada
he seemed like a nice kid the first
little while it was good but if that was
like the the truth about Canadians that
they were all kind of like rockstars on
the inside is there just a visa inside
of you that if you get a million Twitter
followers are you gonna turn that
adjusted to no that's that's right if I
got a million Twitter followers
affirmative total no but it's been a
tough year for Canadians is between Rob
Ford and Justin Bieber that's the people
are not being well represented I
understand the element of the feel of
Rob Ford which is that it's a politician
who just does what he wants to do and
really goes about is I am a man of the
people I'm a regular guy but there's a
line between that and crack so you're
saying don't do crack is I want to let
you know that if there's one message I
could send to the people of America yeah
it's don't do crap what are you doing
later handsome
it's listen can't thank you enough for
coming by I think your haircuts better
than mine come on be good don't lie to
the people I love I got my own oh I'm
all over it thank you all right let me
know if you need help with the news
later man yeah well you know I am you
know so yeah okay I'm camera-ready
all right could everyone quiet down
please thank you so that was me and Pat
Kiernan the coolest Canadian in New York
City if you liked it click the little
thumbs up weird icon think and for more
of GQ barbershops subscribe to our
Channel see you guys the next time